Welcome to the Heavy Spoilers show I'm your host
Paul and oh my me Lucifer has now come to an end.
The sixth and finale series has a lot
to unpack from it and throughout this
video we're gonna be breaking down the story,
ending and also what we should take from it.
I don't wanna waste any of your time but obviously
this video needs a big spoiler alert on it
so check out if you haven't checked
it out yet. If you enjoy the video
then please hit the thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe for videos like this every day.
With that out the way, thanks for clicking
this, now let's get into Lucifer Season 6.
Ok so Season 5 Part 2 ended with
Lucifer getting a promotion.
After telling Chloe that he loved
her, Lucy beat his brother Michael
and took the position of God. We pick up with
him in on the eve of ascending to the silver city
and it's clear he's getting hot feet as he's
been constantly putting off the new role.
Mirroring this both Maze and Eve decide that they
want to remain on Earth instead of going to Hell
and the pair get engaged early on. This leaves the
spot wide open for a new character to take over
who becomes somewhat of a Negasonic
Teenage Warhead in Lucifers Life.
I wanna just focus on this storyline
for the first part of the video but
we will be touching upon the
other plot lines at the end.
Now the season ends with Lucifer actually
returning to hell and rather than accepting
God's place in Heaven he builds a home there
helping people alongside his partner Chloe.
Season 5 told us that it was impossible to be
God and to love someone and thus Lucifer kinda
gets the best of both worlds as he's with
her and also helping and healing people.
We know that the souls of the damned are
stuck their because of their feelings of guilt
and regret but Season 5 showed us that it was
possible for those trapped to ascend to heaven.
Dan becomes a paramount character
which showcases this as he of course
died last season and now is trying to escape the
confines of hell so that he can get into heaven.
Thus Lucifer doing this is actually kinder than
what he would be doing if he had've ascended.
He's very much saving lost souls and though
he was initially supposed to be doing this
in the silver city, it makes way more sense
to have him in the underworld carrying out an
action that will save everyone. Those people
are of course trapped there and there was
no way for God to bring them up as it would
be against free will, therefore it's better
for everyone that Lucifer does a Linda and
gets people to journey there on their own.
As we predicted in our Season 5 video,
Amenadiel actually ends up becoming God
but he puts new measures in place that will remove
the mystery from the mysterious ways. The angels
will now walk amongst the humans in order to learn
their ways which will make them better overall.
Now how we get there is quite an interesting
journey and we see the idea of paternal
relationships brought up quite a lot.
After seeing one side of a magician double get
murdered we learn that the culprit was one of
their sons, angered that he wasn't allowed to
take over the legacy and sell it off to Netflix.
This makes Lucifer question if he's truly
worthy to step into his father's shoes.
By the end he becomes somewhat more than that
but we'll talk about it later on in the video.
Now speaking of fathers and their children we
see this idea carried across to Lucifer and his
daughter. It's sort of like poetry they rhyme as
we see that in the same way his father was God
and he ruled over hell, that when he starts
to become God his daughter Aurora does too.
After making somewhat of an alliance with Dan
the crazy murder angel travels to Earth with him
and here the truth is revealed. Throughout the
season we learn that she is actually from the
future and that she's back because
Lucy abandoned both her and Chloe.
A big question hangs over the season,
namely why Lucifer would leave and it
becomes somewhat of a self fullfilling
prophecy as we watch it all play out.
Now this idea of absent fathers was
of course mirrored in his own dad
who ended up leaving his kids to his own devices.
His daughters journey very much mirrors
Lucifer's when you think about it
and much like him she journied from hell to
our world in order to confront her father.
However whereas God abandoned his kids,
Lucifer states that he won't and the
second half of the season revolves around
the mystery of why he decided to go. Hell,
even the nickname of Lucy being short for Lucifer
is reflected in Aurora getting the nickname Rory
the both of which are normally used
as names of their gender opposites.
We discover lots of things about the
future, namely that when Chloe died
that Lucifer wasn't there at her side and
we actually see why this plays out in the
finale. With Heaven not having someone on the
throne the apocalypse has started to happen
due to angels answering everyone's
prayers and making a mess of it.
Thus he needs to make a choice, either stay
with his daughter or take on his duties.
Vincent is inadvertently freed and to make matters
worse Chloe finds out she's pregnant with Rory
which puts further pressure on Lucifer. It all
comes to a head in the final episode and after
Lucifer says his good-cries and Rory forgives him
which finally allows him to move on guilt free.
This is mirrored in Dan, who
after possessing Vincent gets
a heart to heart with his daughter
and this finally he goes to heaven.
Unfortunately, this frees Vincent who kidnaps
Chloe and he takes her to 10th and Swanson which
is the faithful location that he disappeared.
The final episode called Partners til the end
has a lot of meaning. Vincent ends up
taking the blades from Rory's wings and
he turns her into a weapon. It leads to one of
the best action scenes in the entire series.
Unfortunately Chloe is stabbed in their
charge and this leads to Lucifer facing
off against Vincent himself. We realise that
his greatest desire is to see Rory grows up
and not being able to do this will
be somewhat his own personal hell.
Lucifer agrees to give his own life
to save her but Rory breaks free,
calls Lucifer dad for the first time
and she goes almost full mask off mode,
nearly revealing her devil face. However Lucifer
convinces her not to kill him so that she doesn't
go down the dark path that he did and just before
it full takes over she spares Vincents life.
Unfortunately for him he still tries to kill Lucy
one last time but Chloe arrives and shoots him.
Instead of what Dan saw he just witnesses darkness
and we do see him in hell in the final few scenes.
Though it seems like a happy ending, due
to Rory not disappearing we realise that
the future hasn't been changed. However
we realise that Lucifer pointing Dan in a
direction in which he could end up going to Heaven
helped him a lot and this is reflected in Rory.
They come to the conclusion that her travelling
back in time was so that he could heal her and
that in hell he'll be able to do more good to the
souls that also need a hand. Lucifer is very much
a character that knows what it's like to fall and
rise and that he'd been put on this path by god.
Hell doesn't need a helper, it needs a
healer and he goes into the underworld
in order to save the lost souls and
sinners. The time loop is very much
complete with the future having impact on the
past and the past then creating the future.
Rory returns to her own time and Lucifer
and Chloe have their final farewell for now
I'm not crying you're crying and we see
Amenadiel in Heaven ushering forth his new plan,
Ella's initiative to inspire young women and
girls to take up science careers is launched,
Dan and Charlotte reunite in the
afterlife, Chloe returns to the LAPD,
Amendial and Linda celebrate Charlie's
birthday and he gets his wings.
Maze and Eve work together to take criminals and
the group all welcome Baby Rory to the world.
After a big time jump we see the story that Rory
told us about and join Chloe on her deathbed. Rory
returns to this moment from the past to thank his
mother for allowing her to go through the steps
her own way. Now I dunno who this old lady was
but shoutouts to the actress for getting me to
cry like that. Rather than having any regrets or
guilt, Chloe says she wouldn't change a thing and
we watch as her partners up until the end with
Lucifer in a duplicate of Linda's therapy room.
Better Call Lucifer is in full effect
and he councils Reese Getty who you may
remember from earlier in the series. Joined by
Vincent we watch as he is truly helping people
and he and Chloe kiss as they start
the rest of eternity together.
It's the perfect way to end
the season and we close out to
welcome to the black parade by chemical romance.
This song is about a patient
looking back on his life and
the memories that he has of it. Death appears
to him and manifests as his fondest ones
and the lyrics we'll carry on carry
a lot of meaning as we know that this
is the end but that the characters are
going on to happier times without us.
It really knocks it out the park and is
an amazing send off for the characters.
As for the season as a whole I think this
got better the longer that it went on
and though it started off a bit slow,
by the end I was sad to see it go.
Now most of the seasons so far have had a fun
episode that sort of breaks the fourth wall
and whereas in the past we got musical ones,
here we get a full animated episode called
Yabba Dabba Do Me. Drawn in the style of a
Hannah Barbara cartoon, it looks incredible
and feels like one of the high points in the
season...scratch that the series. It's episodes
like this that make Lucifer stand out from other
shows and after Lucifer comes face to face with
a version of himself as the devil and it's
a really introspective look at the character
that takes a trip back to the 80s...like a very
stereotypical 80s. Stranger Things kinda 80s.
It's stuff like that which is why I'm gonna
be sad to see the series go and it's a very
bittersweet finale that I hope isn't the
end. I know it is...but you can always hope.
Now juxtaposing this fun stuff we
also get way more serious plotlines
involving Amenadial as he deals with
racism and corruption in the force.
Dan also has a great arc too that reminded
me a lot of Randall and Hopkirk, deceased.
Incase you haven't heard of it, and I'm showing
my age, it was a police sitcom from the 70s in
which a policeman's partner died and he came
back as a ghost to help his buddy solve crimes.
Linda becomes somewhat of a therapist to
the celestials, Adam shows up and Eve and
Maze get married. All of the plot lines
come together to make quite a strong send
off and closing of the book for these characters
that we've come to know and love over the years.
Unfortunately I do feel like the early
part of the season falls into the usual
murder of the week trope and in all honesty
I've never found these all that interesting.
Clocking in at 10 hours I think that the
show could've focused on the main plot points
and cut down it's run time to tell a story that
felt more immediate and gripping. I know it
dropped today but I actually early access to the
season a couple of weeks ago and when I think back
on it those parts are the most forgettable
to me. The main points that will stick with
me are the sentimental ones such as Lucifer
(episode 6) and his daughters relationship.
It does feel like the finale that we've been
wanting and in some ways expecting since the
first one and overall I did enjoy it even
if I do feel there's some pacing issues.
I am judging the series as a
whole but if I was just going
off the final episode, especially that
last half hour it would be a 10 out of 10.
However looking at the series as a whole
I have to take everything into account
and thus it gets a strong.
8/10
Now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you leave all
the devil in the details you thought
about the season in the comments below.
We're running a competition right now and giving
away 3 copies of the Zack Snyder DC Trilogy on
the 30th Of September. All you have to do to be
in with a chance of winning is like the video,
make sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode. We pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now so
message me @heavySpoilers if that's you.
If you want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of perfect
scene in Spider-Man Homecoming.
We break down the entire thing
so it's definitely worth checking
out if you wanna know more.
With that out the way thank you
for sitting through the video,
I’ve been Paul and I’ll see
you next time. Take care, Peace